[موسيقى]
لا نازله الشيخ
ه العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
الخزانه الامريكيه تعلن عن عقوبات ضد
المدعي العام الايراني واربعه من قاده
الحرس الثوري
بعد مفاوضات استمرت لاسابيع بنيامين
نتنياهو يعلن توصل الاتفاق لتشكيل حكومه
جديده
شنغهاي الصينيه تعلنوا انتشار كورونا
وتتوقع اصابه نحو 13 مليون نسمه بالفيروس
اهلا بكم الى نشره الساعه نبدا من
اوكرانيا حيث اوضح الرئيس بولدي
ميوزيلنسكي خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره
الامريكي جومايدن في البيت الابيض اوضح ان
التوصل الى سلام عادل مع روسيا يعني عدم
وجود تنازلات فيما يتعلق بسياده اوكرانيا
ووحده اراضيها من جانبه اكد بيد ان بلاده
لديها نفس الرؤيه المتمثله في اوكرانيا
حره ومستقله مزدهره وامنه في المقابل
اشاره الكرملين الى انه لا يرى اي فرصه
لاجراء محادثات سلام معك كيف مؤكدا مواصله
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
هذا واعتبر السفيره الروسي في واشنطن
اناتلي انت نوف ان زياره الرئيس الاوكراني
ايفلادي ميرسي الى الولايات المتحده تدل
على عدم استعاده الطرفين للسلام والتهمه
الدبلوماسيه الروسيين واشنطن بالسعي الى
استمرار الصراع نفيا ويطرح في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه بان روسيا غير مهتمه
بتحقيق السلام
وكان رئيس الاوكراني
كلمه امام الكونجرس اكد فيها ان المساعده
التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده لبلاده
للتصدي للغزو الروسي ليست صدقه بل هي
استثمار في الامن العالمي واكد ذلك ان
القوات الاوكرانيه الصامده في مواقعها ولن
تستسلم ابدا قبل ان يقدم للكونجرس على من
اوكرانيه انجلبه معه من ارض المعركه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لا لا
وقف هذه الحرب الفظيعه والولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بضمان استمرار الشعب الاوكراني
شجاع في الدفاع عن بلاده ضد العدوان
الروسي طالما استغرق الامر ذلك
رئيس السلام العادل ليست التنازلات فيما
يتعلق بالسياده بلدي وحريته وسلامته
الاقليميه
طبعا رئيس الاوكراني لم يعد الى بلاده
خالي الايدي ولكنه عاد بهدايا العيد عيدهم
المبكره حيث اعلنت الولايات المتحده اعلنت
ارسال شحنه جديده من المساعدات
ان الحزمه الجديده المتوقعه ستتضمن هذه
الحزمه المزيد من المساعدات ومجموعه من
قنابل دقيقه من شانها تحويل الذخائر غير
الموجوده الى قنابل ذكيه موجهه بدقه تعرف
باسم ذخائر الهجوم المباشر المشترك
سنواصلوا تعزيز قدره اوكرانيا للدفاع عن
نفسها وخاصه الدفاع الجوي ولهذا سبب سنزود
اوكرانيا ببطاريه صواريخ باتريوت
نظيفه
عن حزمه جديده
معنى من بريزه كتب الصحفي اسامه الحريري
اهلا بك سيد اسامه اذا الحزمه جديده من
هذه المساعدات هل ستؤدي الى فصل جديد من
الهجوم الشرس من المعارك الشرسه عراء على
ارض المعركه ام ربما سترسم خارطه الطريق
الى المفاوضات
صباح الخير
الاوروبيه بشكل عام
التي بداته باعطائها اوكرانيا
عفوا هذه المساعدات مثلا بطاريه الباتريوت
كانت ترفض امريكا ان تعطيها الى اوكرانيا
قدمتها بشكل تدريجي جدا في بدايه الحرب
طبعا كان هناك حديث عن اسلحه طلبات
المتحده والولايات المتحده يعني رفضت
علماء او اجلت الموضوع بالتالي
او المعسكر الغربي
الولايات المتحده باعطاء اكبر كميه ممكنه
من الاسلحه وكافه انواع الاسلحه الهجوميه
ايضا الى اوكرانيا
على بشكل واضح وصريح قال ان الهدف في
النهايه هو اعطاء اسلحه دفاعيه وانه اذا
تمت
طاء جميع هذه الاسلحه الاوكرانيا ذلك
سيهدد وحده حلف الناتو ووحده همم معسكر
الغربي وسيؤدي الى شرده مثل هذا المعسكر
لا يريدون انتصار اوكرانيا وانما يريدون
اطاله اما هذه الحرب
يعني انا احبك
[موسيقى]
روسيا يريدون اكثر انتصار اوكرانيا ولكن
يعني في نفس الوقت هناك مخاوف غربيه كبيره
جدا من انهيار روسيا بشكل كبير كان هناك
مثلا ايام قال لي كيسنجر او او يعني
القائد الخارجيه الفرنسيه بنى حرب البارده
قال فيه ان هناك خطا الحقيقي في حاله
روسيا اليوم اليوم من الميكروه وهو عائد
يعني يوم امس عفوا على طائره من الاردن
خلال المؤتمر الاخير قالها بشكل واضح يجب
ان يهيء الارضيه للمفاوضات لكي لا نصل الى
مرحله لا يكون فقط الاتراك الصينيين هم
الذين يعني ياخذون المفاوضات لمرحله ما
بعد الحرب بالتالي يعني هذه همم الزياره
التي قام بها الانسان التاريخيه زياره ذات
اهميه كبيره جدا
في التوجه يعني احد اهدافها الاساسيه كانت
توجه الى الشعب الامريكي الشعب الامريكي
هذا الشعب الذي بحسب الاحصاءات الاخيره
واستطلاعات الراي تنخفض يعني ينخفض زخم
دعمه ليه اوكرانيا يوما بعد يوم بحسب اخر
استطلاع للراي 48% من الشعب الامريكيه
يعتقد انه يجب دعم اوكرانيا الى اخر
الحدود مما يشكل يعني انخفاضا مقارنه مع
الاشهر الماضيه بالتالي هذا الجنسي كان
واضحا التوجه الى الشعب الامريكي والتوجه
اي
ضا في الكونغرس الى النواب الامريكيين
ونحن يعني نعرف جيدا خلال الانتخابات
النصفيه الاخيره
بعض المطرب
اسامه
في اوكرانيا وهذه المساعدات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا ماذا يحتاج بعد اذنك من من
بايدا يعني ماذا بعد الباتريوت هل يمكن ان
نرى ربما هاي مارس 300 ربما اف 160 التي
ايضا يطالب بهذا الاسم
ان يصل الامر الى حد الطائرات المقاتله لا
اعتقد شخصيا ولكن طبعا يعني في الحروب
كلها الاحتمالات التوارده وتبقى مفتوحه
ولكن اما بخصوص منظومات دفاعيه وقد نعم من
غير ان نستبعد بطاطا في الاشهر الماضي او
بعد انتهاء فصل الشتاء في حال تغيرت
موازين القوه في حاله تغيرت المعارف في
حاله استطاع تونسي التقدم مجددا نعم لا
نستبعد بدتاه ان تقدم الولايات المتحده
اسلحه الدفاعيه اخرى وبالمناسبه يعني
حاليا فرنسا وايطاليا تدرس ايضا امكانيه
تقديم منظومه دفاعيه همم من نوع الى
اوكرانيا بالتالي نعم الولايات المتحده
كما قالها بعيد يعني بالامس لا اعتقد انها
ستترك اوكرانيا في منتصف الطريق
خاصه ان الامور لم تحسم بعد يعني اوكرانيا
بحاجه الى نص العسكري كبير جدا لكي يتم
بعدها ربما الجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات
هناك في الوقت الحالي جميع المؤشرات تشير
الى انها هذه الحرب ستطول اكثر ستطول اكثر
خصوصا مع روسيا وايضا تصريحات همم
تصريحات موسكو بالامس همم تصريحات الرئيس
الروسي همم بانه سيكون هناك مزيد من
التسليح سيكون هناك لا حدود لماذا ميزانيه
التسليح وتطوير الاسلحه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بالتالي ما ردود الروسيه
المتوقعه خصوصا وان بطاريه الباترول تحتاج
الى تدريب كبير من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
وقد تاخذ الى اشهر
صحيح قرابه ربما وثلاثه اشهر لكي يبدا
الجيش اللبناني باستخدام هذه البطاريه
بالتالي وهنا الحديث كان في السابق على ان
فصل الشتاء يعني لن يشهد فعليا تقدما
كبيرا في المعارك لكلا الطرفين ولكن يعني
الروسي يعني انا هنا اريد ان اطرح سؤال
روسيا كانت وضعت خطوطا حمر كثيره روسيا
كانت سبق هو خالد انه في حال تم الاعتداء
على اراضيها سيكون الرد مسلسل وسيكون قويا
ونحن رعينا يعني اوكرانيا استطاعت ان تحرر
خرسانه ومناطق اخرى تعتبرها روسيا من بعد
انا اسال سيد اسامه
بالداخل الروسي ولكن لم نرى اي رد روسي
يعني همم تصعيدي غير انها همم شدت في
القصف الصاروخي وما الى ذلك بالتالي ماذا
تتوقع لان لان الامكانيات الروسيه ضعيفه
يعني الروسيه حسب يعني اصبحت الثوره
الطائرات مسيره من ايران هي وصلت الى هذه
الدرجه يعني
امكانيات المحدوده ولكن قوه روسيا قوه
روسيا الحقيقيه تبقى في مساله يعني نفس
الطويل منسى يستطيع ان يصمد اكثر بحسب
يعني وجهه نظر بوتين لان الشعب الرئيسيه
متعود جدا على نعم هل يعقل يعني روسيا
الدوله
الكبيره دوله يعني همم متخضمه في صناعه
الاسلحه دوله مهياه حسب الخبراء لهذه
الحرب منذ سنوات لا يكون لديها الكافي من
الاسلحه لديها نقص من الاسلحه
اعتقد نعم من ناحيه انه كان هناك خطا في
الحسابات قام به بروتين ربما كان يعتقد ان
الحرف في اوكرانيا ستكون مذهله لم يتمكن
يتوقع هذا هذه الوحده من قبل حل الشمال
الاطلسي رغم الخلافات يعني لم يكن يتوقع
هذه الوحده منذ اليوم الاول يعني استطاعت
اوكرانيا هو هزم بدايه من الشمال واستطاع
ان يحتل همم مناطق في ضواحي كيابو بعدها
تم تحريره يعني حتى الان المعظم الاراضي
التي قامت اوكرانيا في تحريرها وهذا دليل
واضح على الفشل الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
التي وضعتها روسي انها ستكون يعني نصفها
في افريقيا
على الحدود راينا همم زياره بوتين الى بلا
روسيا هل يمكن ان نرى دخول بيلاروسيا بشكل
مباشر في هذه الحرب او ربما قصف روسي من
خلال بلاروسيا
يعني هناك جميع الخبراء العسكري العسكريون
يعني يتفقون على موضوع بشان بيلاروسيا
هناك احتمالا
الاحتمال الاول هو ان كل ما تقوم به
روسيا هو نوع من المسرحيه لتجديد انتباه
الجيش الاوكراني على جبهات اخرى ولي اييي
يعني وليجر اوكراني على ارسال جنودها الى
الحدود الروسيه في المقابل يعني اضعافها
على جبهات اخرى هذه هذا احتمال اما
الاحتمال الاخر هو فعلا ان تقوم روسيا
بعمليه عسكريه جديده من الاراضي الفيلا
الروسيه كما قامت به يعني همم في في
البدايه انطلاقه من هذه الاراده ولكن هنا
يبقى السؤال
رئيس الدوله الروسي هل هو مستعد للتضحيه
وارسال ايضا جنوده
بلا روسيه هي معارضه قويه جدا لا تقارن
بالمعارضه في الشارع الروسي هناك في
بيلاروسيا هناك معارضه
منظمه رغم حماله القمع وهناك حتى في الجيش
الروسي هناك لا توجد رغبه ابدا في اختراق
عسكريه في هذه الحرب شكرا من باريس الكاتب
الصحفي اسامه الحريري
اصيب مسؤولا كبيران مواليا لروسيا في قصف
اوكرانيا استهدفه فندق في مدينه دنيتك
وفادت وكاله الانباء الروسيه ان احد
المصابين هو ديمتري روجوزين الذي تولى في
السابق منصب نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي لكن
اصابته لا تهدد حياته اما المصاب الثاني
فهو فيتالي اختينكو رئيس حكومه جمهوريه
الشعبيه التي نصب بنفسه واشار عضو في
البرلمان الروسي الى ان المهاجمين تصرف
بنا على معلومه تم تسريبها اليهم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
اذا ماتوا قرار طالبان منع تعليم
الافغانيات تتوالى والاتحاد الاوروبي يصفه
بالجريمه ضد الانسانيه
احييكم من جديد اعلانات وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه عن حزمه جديده من العقوبات ضد
ايران تشمل هذه الحزمه اربعه من قاده
الحرس الثوري والفاسيج
ومسؤولون عن قمع الاحتجاجات خاصه في
محافظه كردستان ايران اضافه الى المدعي
العام في طهران محمد منتظري الذي كان سببا
في محاكمات المحتجين من جهتها اكدت
الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان الولايات
المتحده ستواصلوا دعم الايرانيين في
مواجهه القمع التي يمارسها النظام ضد
المحتاجين بالاضافه الى حشد الاجماع
الدولي المتزايد بمحاسبه النظام الايراني
كما اشار البيان الى ان المحاكم الايرانيه
اصدرت احكاما قاسيه ضد المتظاهرين بينها
عقوبه الاعدام بعد محاكمات سوريه وطلبه
الخارجيه الامريكيه السلطات الايرانيه
بالوقوف الفوريه لعمليات القمع والاستماع
الى مطالب المحتجين
قام هو الاحتجاجات في ايران على طهران
عرضه للسيل المتواصل من الانتقادات
والتمديدات اخر اتهام مواجهته منظمه هيومن
رايتس واتش الى قوات الامن الايرانيه
باستخدام القوه المفرطه غير القانونيه
والمفضيه الى الموت ضد المتظاهرين في
مدينه صننج وضعت المنظمه بعثت الامم
المتحده لتقصي الحقائق بشان ايران طبعا
التحقيق في هذه الانتهاكات الجسيمه ونقل
بيان المنظمه تاكيدا على ممارسه السلطات
الايرانيه عنفا وصفته بالمقلق ضد
المتظاهرين في سننج منذ سبتمبر الماضي
ينضم الينا في الاستديو الباحث في الشان
الايراني الصالح حميد اهلا بك معنا سيد
صالح في استديوهاتنا في الرياض ابن عقوبات
جديده على كيانات وقاده في الحرس الثوري
الايراني الى اي مذهب هذه العقوبات حقيقه
فاعله
في وقف القتل المباشر لمتظاهرين في
الشوارع ووقف العنف المنهج والتعذيب في
السجون لكنها تترك تاثيرا معنويا كبيرا
وتاثيرا سياسيا ايضا لان هذا يعني ان
هؤلاء اولا همم تتم توثيق الانتهاكات
ومرتكبها ثانيا همم راينا الكثير من
المسؤولين الايرانيين الذين يرتكبون جرائم
ثم همم يسافرون الى مختلف الدول ولديهم
صالح مثل ما حدث في حاله حميد نوري مثلا
الذي كان نائب المدعي العام في همم في سجن
جوهر داش في كرج وكان احد المنافذين
لعمليات الاعدام الجامعيه ضد السجناء
السياسي في الثمانينات عندما تم توثيق
اكاتي تم اعتقاله في السويد وحكم عليه
بالسجن 20 عاما هذا همم يعني يجعل سائر
المسؤولين والمسؤولين عن القمع بشكل مباشر
ان يحسبوا الف حساب قبل ان يسافروا او حتى
في كيفيه ممارسه القمع ونشر ذلك عبر
الفيديوهات لتخويف الناس ايضا هذا سيعطي
زخما اكثر همم للاعتجاجات في السابق لم
يكن تسقيط الضوء بهذا الشكل على
الاحتجاجات على عمليات القاتل على وكان
النظام يقتل والمجتمع الدولي صامت او حتى
يفاوض النظام يمنحه المليارات ويستمر
الايرانيين يعني يجدون طرق يعني طرق
ملتويه حول هذه العقوبات في ظل هذا يعني
كيف يمكن فعلا تطبيقها وان تاتي يعني تاتي
كلها وتاثيرها كما تتحدث حضرتك يعني هو
هذا الفرق هذه المره في سابق يعني همم كان
النظام يعتقد انه يستخدم اسلوب القمع في
الداخل وفي الخارج في ظل همم التفاوض وهمم
استخدام الملف النووي كورق للتفاضل للبقاء
على علاقه في المجتمع الدولي وفي الحقيقه
خداع المجتمع الدولي بانه يريد ان يصحح من
سلوكه طيله هذه السنوات كانت هذه سياسه
مستمره الان الوضع مختلف الان همم هناك
قرارات امنيه همم تم طرد همم النظام من
لجنه المراه في الامم المتحده شكلت لجنه
لتقص الحقائق من قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان
ثلاث سيدات من الخبراء المستقلين الامم
المتحده تم تعيينهم لكي يذهبوا الى ايران
ويحقق في هذه الانتهاكات طبعا ايران ترفض
هذا لكن هذه ايضا همم وسيله ضغط اضافيه
الايرانيه طيب سيد صالح همم يعني ماذا
يمكن ان تكون الشوكه التي ممكن ان تكسر
ظهر النظام الايراني وتؤدي فعلا الى
تنازلات تؤدي الى فعلا تغيير النظام وتلبي
مطالب المحتاجين في الداخل الايراني
دائما كانت يعني خلال 40 عام لا يقدم اي
تنازلات الا انه يشعر انه وصل الى حافه
الهاويه مثلا لماذا ذهب الاتفاق النووي
عام 2013 الى المفاوضات عندما وصل الى
انهيار الاقتصاد الان ايضا اذا شعر النظام
انه في عزله همم وهناك المزيد من الضغوط
والعقوبات وليست تفاوض وملح لمليارات
عندها فقط همم على تقديم تنازلات وسيسمح
همم للجنه التقصف الحقائق بالدخول وربما
بعض التعاون معها لكن اذا استمر الوضع
المهاد الاوروبي الامريكي همم بالتاكيد
النظام بالداخل سيستمر همم بالقمع فهذه
العلاقه طرديه هي علاقه هذا النظام الذي
يفكر بعقليه شموليه بانه من خلال القمع
والقتل والترهيب يستطيع
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات لكن لحد الان كانت
نتائج عكسيه كل ما قتل نظام اكثر كل ما
استمرت المظاهرات بشكل اكبر بشكل اكبر
لمطالبه بلا ابسط حقوقهم في الداخل
الايراني سيد صالح همم يعني هل انت
المتابع والخبير في هذا الشان هل الانباء
الوارده من الداخل الايراني تشير باي شكل
من الاشكال الى شعورهم بالعزله شعورهم
بالاختناق بالطبع يعني هناك صراع في راس
الهرم حول كيفيه التعاطي مع الاحتجاجات
بدات اصوات تخرج همم يعني بعض مثلا همم
الشخصيات المقربه من النظام همم من
الاصلاحين الذين خارج الحكم الان همم
يناشدون المرشد بان يطلق سراح همم
المعتقلين وحسب بعض الاحصائيات غير رسميه
وصل عددهم لها 30,000 كثير ماتوا تحت
تعذيب همم يعني هناك 56 محتاج قتلوا بشكل
مباشر 68 منهم اطفال هذا بالتاكيد يعطي
نتائج عكسيه كسر هناك اصدقاء كل ما يسقط
قتيل تخرج الناس في هذه المدينه وتحول
مراسم التشع الى احتجاجات جديده وهكذا
يستمر الوضع يعني النظام اعتقد انه في ظل
هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره والضغوط الدوليه
لابد له ان يصل الى مرحله ان يقدم هذه
التنازلات على الاقل يطلق همم صراحه
المعتقلين من السجون همم يعني يرضخ لبعض
الشروط والمطالب ولكن لا اعتقد انه سوف
يغير سلوكه بشكل كلي
صالح يعني تحدث بانهم يصرون كل ما زاد
القمع وكل ما زاد اسراره من اين لهم هذا
الاسرار من اين لهم هذه القوه في ان يستمر
رغم الاضطهاد والتعذيب والقتل والاعتقال
من اين لهم همم
تاريخ في همم لكن همم
رساله هذا النظام اوصلتهم الى الفقر الى
الجوع الى الادمن على المخدرات يعني
الشبان
والمجتمع الايران المجتمع فتي يعني نسبه
الشباب هم الغالبيه لذلك يقولون انه لم
يعد لدينا شيء لنخسره وسيقضي علينا هذا
النظام الواحد تلو الاخر اذا لم نتحرك ولم
ننهض لنرسم مستقبلنا ولذلك نرى شعارات
جذريه وراء ذكاليه تطالب بالتغيير الكلي
والشامل شكرا للانضمامك معنا في الاستديو
الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح حميد
اعلنا بنيامين نتنياهو اطول رئيس الوزراء
بقاء في المنصب في اسرائيل اعلن عن التوصل
الى اتفاق لتشكيل حكومه جديده بعد
المفاوضات صعبه على غير المتوقع استمرت
اسابيع مع شركاء التحالف الدينيين ومن
اليمين المتطرف كذلك
من اليمين الاسرائيلي رساله الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي طلبوا فيها عدم التدخل فيما
وصفوها بالشؤون الاسرائيليه وذلك طبعا في
عقاب الكشف عن وثيقه سريه تتضمن خطه
اوروبيه لدعم سياسيا واقتصاديا وقانونيا
متكامل للفلسطينيين فيما طالبه وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي المكلف باجتماعا للتصدي
لتلك الوثيقه الاوروبيه
الكشف عن اعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي وثيقه
سريه تتضمن خطه لمساعده الفلسطينيين
سياسيا وقانونيا واقتصاديا على بسط
سيطراتهم على المناطق المصنفه جيم التي
تشكل 60% من الضفه الغربيه المحتله قبل
بغضب الاسرائيلي وترحيب فلسطيني نحن
نتحدثنا مع كل دول العالم حول انه لا يمكن
القبول بان يبقى الاحتلال يحاول منافع
الفلسطيني
وبالتالي يعني العديد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المصنفه تحت هذا البنت تحاول
حكومه الاحتلال السيطره عليها وبناء
وتوسيع المستعمرات الاسطانيه الوثيقه
الواقعه في ست صفحات تتحدث عن قيام
الاتحاد الاوروبي بترسيم خارطه للاراضي في
مناطق جيم والعمل قانونيه على اثبات
ملكيتها الفلسطينيه
ومراقبه النشاط الاثريه الاسرائيلي لانه
احدى ادوات فرض السيطره الاسرائيليه
والعمل من خلال مشاريع قانوني على دمج
مناطق جيم مع مناطق الف تحت سياده
الفلسطينيه وبال خاضعه لسيطره المدنيه
الفلسطينيه
فيما اعلى نوع وزير الماليه والوزير في
وزاره الدفاع مدرج انه سيطلق فورا تسلمه
المنصب حمله لهدم البناء الفلسطيني في
مناطق جيم ويعمل على ضم الضفه لاسرائيل
هذه هي العلامه الاولى لما ينتظرنا من
توتر ومواجه بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
العقيده مع الدعم الاوروبي والامريكي
للفلسطينيين في منطقه تاثير في الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيل ترفض تقليديا اي دور سياسي
لاوروبا في عمليه التسويه وتصر على انفراد
واشنطن في ادارتها رغم انها لم تعد قائمه
منذ سنوات لا تخفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه المتطرفه وشيكه الولاده انها
ستعمل على ضم الضفه الغربيه المحتله
لاسرائيل وانهاء حل الدولتين على الارض
ويبدو ان العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
المتفجره الطبيعه ستظل تدور في فلك تعقيد
والتصعيد زياد حلبي العربيه الضفه الغربيه
المحتله
من القدس تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه لانا
كالغاسي اهلا بك لانا اااه لماذا في اخر
لحظه بنيامين نتنياهو انتظر لاعلان
الحكومه او ليقول ان هناك حكومه وتشكيله
واضحه في باله
يعني نعم تحديدا قبل 12 دقيقه فقط من
انتهاء التفويض الممنوع لرئيس الوزراء
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو قد يعني اتصل
بالرئيس الاسرائيلي
انه فعليا قد نجح بتشكيل حكومه السادسه
هذه هي حكومه السادسه ويقوم ايضا بتشكيل
هذه الحكومه الاسبوع
القادم وذلك بعد 38
يوما من المفاوضات دعينا نقول الشرسه اما
بالنسبه للتسلسل الزمني الموعد
المبدا لعرض هذه الحكومه على الكنيسه
سيكون الاسبوع القادم وتحديدا يوم
الاربعاء القادم يوم الاربعاء القادم
بالتالي سيكون دخل فتره الوقت الاضافي
لتشكيل هذه الحكومه اليس كذلك لانه يسابق
الوقت
لا فعليا يعني الوقت الاضافي قد انتهى
يعني تمكن نتنيهم من تشكيل هذه الحكومه
ولكن هذه القانون حسب القانون الاسرائيلي
حاليا سيقوم او قام فعليا بالاتصال برئيس
الاسرائيلي وقد ابلغوه انه قام بتشكيل هذه
الحكومه ونجح بتشكيل هذا الائتلاف الجديد
ولكن الخطوات
الاولى او المبدئيه التي يجب ان يقوم همم
يعني اعطائها بعد ذلك هو تقديم هذه
الحكومه وتقديم هذا الائتلاف الجديد وعرضه
على الكنيسه هناك انباء تتحدث لنا عن هذه
الحكومه ستكون الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ
اسرائيل وهناك مخاوف في الخارج حول ذلك
كيف هو الوضع في الداخل
يعني فعليا هذه يعني هذه الاقوال هي ليست
بالجديده
بتشكيل او بهذه الحكومه ب 64 مقعدا ففعليا
الاغلبيه من هذه الحكومه هي الحكومه يمنيه
متطرفه يعني نحن نتحدث عن ائتلاف جديد
بدعم اربع احزاب يمينيه متطرفه تدعو الى
بناء المستوطنات بناء مستوطناتهم يريدين
ايضا ال سيطر على الحقائب الحقيبه الماليه
وحقيبه الامن التي تعطيهم القوه لتغيير في
الضفه الغربيه يعني هناك اعضاء او عدد
كبير من الاعضاء ايضا في هذه من الكنيست
في هذه الحكومه الجديده هم ايضا يسكنون
ويقتنون في مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
التي تعاد تحت القانون الدولي هي اراضي
مختلفه نحن نتحدث عن حكومه يمنيه متشدده
تعطي تصاريح للسلاح للمستوطنين ويعني
تعطيهم ولكم حتى ايضا الاعتداء على
المزارع والاراضي الفلسطينيه حتى داخل هذا
الائتلاف لنا يقال بان هناك مشاكل وهناك
بعض من اعضاء الائتلاف ضد بنيامين نتنياهو
بسبب ان غرضه الاساسي هو ربما تشكيل حكومه
باي شكل ليتجنب المحاكمه ما صحه هذه
الانباء
صحيح يعني نتنياهو يعني قدم العديد من
التنازلات من اجل تشكيل هذه الحكومه وهو
مبدا الاساسي فعليا الهروب من المحاكم
الاسرائيليه وتشكيل حكومته الجديده باي
ثمن همم موجود فلذلك راينا التنازلات التي
قدمها لبنك فير بس ما ادريش وايضا العديد
من الاعضاء فن نرى انهم نتنياهو الوحيد هو
تشكيل هذه الحكومه بغض النظر عن التنازلات
والمخاطر التي ربما يقدمها للاسرائيليين
وايضا الاسرائيليين العلمانيين يعني هناك
اعتراض كبير على هذه الحكومه المتطرفه ضد
العلمانيه شكرا لك من القدس مراسله
العربيه لانك الغاصي
اختبر الاتحاد الاوروبي ان قرار منع
النساء من التعليم في افغانستان يمثل
جريمه ضد الانسانيه كما ادانا بيان لوزاره
الخارجيه الدول السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
بالاضافه الى دول اخرى بشده قرارات طالبان
الاخيره من الجامعات واشار البيان الى ان
طالبان بهذه التصرفات تزيد من عزل نفسها
عن السكان الافغان وعن المجتمع الدولي
لانه اذا تم منعه نصف المجتمع الافغاني من
حق التعليم ورسمي مستقبله فهذا ظلم
للمجتمع انا مثلا في السنه الاخيره كنت
ادرس في الصحافه ومثل الكثيرات يدرسنا في
الطب ومجالات التعليم الاخرى التي يحتاجها
المجتمع يجب ان تقتنع السلطات وان منع
الفتيات من التعليم سيؤ لا تدهور الاوضاع
اكثر فاكثر ولا يساعد على الاستقرار
اطالب المجتمع الدولي وكل الدول ان تستمع
لصوت نسائي افغانستان وان يهبوا لنجدتنا
لانه لا احد يسمع صوتنا داخل افغانستان
نحن نشعر اننا وحيدات اذا كنا نحن مواطنات
افغانيات فيجب ان يتم الاعتراف بحقوقنا
ونطالب الامم المتحده وكل المجتمع الدولي
ان يحترموا حقوقنا وان يضغطوا على السلطات
لالغاء هذا القرار المجحف وايضا نناشد
طالبان ونقول لهم دعونا نضع يدا بيد لنبني
بلدنا بدلا من تحميش النساء الافغانيات
وعلينا ان نحترم جميع فئات المجتمع لان
الفتيات هن بنات طالبان ايضا والله لم
يخلق احدا ليضطهد بني جانسه ويجب ان تكون
المحبه هي التي تسود بيننا وليس اضطهاد
بعضنا بعضا
من كابل المراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
اهلا بك عبد الله اذا تضامن واسع حول منع
الفتيات من الدراسه في الجامعات راينا
طلاب يتضامن معهم راينا بروفيسورز في
الجامعه يتضمن يتضامن مع الفتيات كيف هو
وضع الاحتجاجات الان هناك نداءات
الاحتجاجات ضد هذه القرارات
صباح اليوم على اشهر جامعات في العاصمه
كابل ابواب المدارس والمعاهد والجامعات
المغلقه امام الفتيات امام الشبان الافغان
فيدخلون للقاعات الدراسيه
وقد اعلنت منذ امس مجموعتهم من السيدات
والفتيات الجامعيات همم الخروج في مسيرات
وتظاهرات همم اليوم صباح اليوم في الساعه
التاسعه على توقيت كابل من امام البوابه
الرئيسيه من جامعه كابو اكبر واشهر جامعه
في في افغانستان ولكنه ذهب في التوقيت الى
هذه البوابه ولم نجد اي اثر للتظاهرات لم
تكن هناك تظاهرات في البوابه الشماليه
للجامعه ولم تكن هناك تظاهرات ومسيرات في
البوابه الجنوبيه ثم قيل لنا ان تظاهرات
قد نظ في منطقه همم بوليسوخته التي تقطنها
الاقليه الشيعه في في مدينه كابول وفي
العاصمه كابل ذهبنا الى هناك لم تكن كذلك
هناك تظاهرات
عبدالله لم يكن هناك مظاهرات هل القوه
الامنيه تقوم بمنع هذه المظاهرات
ثم قيل لنا ان عددا من الفتيات والسيدات
خرجت في منطقه كارتيسي جنوب غرب العاصمه
و ذهبنا الى هذه المنطقه فقيل لنا ان
القوات الامنيه والاجهزه الامنيه قام
بتفريق هذا العدد من السيدات في هذه
المنطقه وبالتالي همم لم تكون هناك
تظاهرات في العاصمه كابول وكذا الحال في
بقيه المدن الكبرى وذلك لسببين السبب
الاول ان القوات الامنيه منتشره بكثافه
جدا في جميع الشوارع همم في العاصمه كابل
بحسب المشاهده وكذلك في همم في الضواحي
الشرقيه والشماليه للعاصمه كابل وكذلك في
المدن الكبرى للمقاطعات الاخرى وثانيا ان
همم
الجميع يعرف ان هذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
والانتقادات اللاذعه على هذا القرار همم
لن تكون نجاحه
ولم تكن همم لها اي اي صدى همم للتظاهرات
السابقه على قرارات طالبان السابقه بمنع
او باغلاق المدارس الابتدائيه فوق الصف
السادس الابتدائي وبمنعي الفتيات والسيدات
من الملاهي
وما الى وصالونات الالعاب همم وهناك اسباب
الابتدائيه للفتيات سيتم منعها هل هذا
صحيح ما صحه هذه الانباء
همم هذه همم
التقارير وصلتنا ولكنها لحد الان لا
نستطيع ان نؤكد هذه التقارير حتى تصدر
حركه طالبان قرارا مجرما باغلاق هذه
المدارس الابتدائيه ولكنها لحد الان ليست
مغلقه يبدو ان التظاهرات ضد هذا القرار
الاخير همم لن تستمر كثيرا وذلك لسببين
السبب الاول ان التظاهرات ضد قرارات
طالبان لن لن تفيد والثاني ان الصبر
والمثابره والتحمل لدى الشبان والفتيات
الافغانيات قد يضم حل واستنزف همم الطاقه
البشريه لدى الشبان الافغان في هذه
السنوات الاربعين همم الماضيه همم
المتاح امامهم غير انهم يتظاهرون ضد هذه
القرارات
ولكنهم لا يتظاهرون
وسبب ان يتم تفريقه السيدات والتفريق
المظاهرات وكذلك في بعض الحالات يتم قمع
هذه التظاهرات وبالتالي نحن كنا نتوقع ان
تخرج تظاهرات ومسيرات في المدن الكبرى
الافغانيه ولكن ما حدث كان غير متوقع
فالداخل الافغاني عليه اما الصمت او
الرحيل
او مغادره البلد الخارج
مما قد يفعله القوات الافغانيه بهم
والخروج الى الخارج ليس متاح للجميع بسبب
كما نعلم الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه
والماديه لدى اغلب الاسر الافغانيه شكرا
لك من كابل مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
عزيزه ابدا لي طالبه جامعيه تدرس في كليه
الطب منعتها طالبان من الذهاب الى الجامعه
تقول ان طموحاتها قد ذهبت ادراج الرياح
كما ذهب الطموحات زميلاتها
ولكن طالبان الان من عدنان
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات لنحو 16 شهرا ما اثار انتقادات
داخليه لم تؤدي الى نتائج ملموسه
ليس لدينا خيار اخر لمواصله الدراسه داخل
البلاد فاذا اردنا الدراسه علينا المغادره
للخارج
[موسيقى]
الاخير اثار ادانات دوليه متعدده وضغوطا
على حركه طالبان للتراجع عنه طالب
امرها بانها تن
شغل فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير مقتنعات
بهذه التمريرات لان طالبان على سده الحكم
منظر نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها ان تتغلب
على هذه المشاكل ايا كانت عبدو نادر
العربيه كابول
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ناس الامريكيه
تعلن رسميا تقاعد مركبه الفضاء الموجوده
في المريخ انسايت
اهلا بكم من جديد في الصين ابلغ مستشفى في
شنغهاي موظفي بالاستعداد لما وصفه بمعركه
ماساويه مع فيروس كرونه حيث يتوقع او
يتوقع اصابه نصف سكان المدينه البالغ
عددهم 25 مليون نسمه بحلو نهايه العام
وفقرويترز ويشتاق هذا الفيروس الصين من
دون رابع تحولها
عن سياسه صفر كوفد وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه اعلنت ان الجيش الصيني ارسل 39
طائره وثلاثه سفن حربيه باتجاه تايوان
خلال 24 ساعه وبيحسب الوزاره عبرت
الطائرات او عبرت الطائرات الصينيه خط
الوسط لمضيق تايوان وهو حدود غير رسميا
قابلها الجانبان ضمينيا ومن بين الطائرات
احده وعشرون مقاتله وطائرتان للانذار
المبكر كما افادت العاصمه تايوانيه
بمراقبه التحركات الصينيه من خلال انظمه
صواريخ ارضيه ومن سفن
هي خاصه بها
الى لبنان حيث تعود الاعياد في ظل ازماته
المتصاعده ولكن مع غياب كرونا استعاده
مواسم الاحتفالات رونقها خلال عام 20 22
في لبنان ومن المتوقع ان يدخل لبنان خلال
شهر واحد 700 الف زائر معظمهم من
المغتربين ما سيؤدي بطبيعه الحال الى دخول
ملايين الدولارات الى لبنان لكن هذه
الدولارات مشاهدينا لن تؤثر على الازمه
الاقتصاديه المستمره مع امتناع اللبنانيين
عن وضعها في المصارف
رغم ان ازمه لبنان لم تطوى صفحتها بعد الا
ان بيروت تبدو وكانها السعاده رونق
اعيادها بخلاف الاعوام الماضيه
وسط المدينه هنا كان اشبه بمدن الاشباح
ليلا لكن الزينه تعادت لتضيء لياليه
من الزهور
اما القرى الميلاد خاصه
[موسيقى]
ايه ده مش احنا رح نقوم بحالنا ما حدا راح
يساعدنا فبتل ما كنا عم نقول قبل انه
القطاع الخاص هو يلي امل هلبلات مزبوط ما
في غير قطاع الخاص هو راح يرجع يقومها
البلد
والسياحه وطبعا من شركه طيران فوق 600000
رح يجي على لبنان هذا الموسم هذا الشهرين
لا تاريخ اليوم صار واصل تقريبا 270,000
طبعا احنا بنقول لك كل اللبنانيين ولكل
سوريا
موسم جديد من المواسم السياحيه يعمل خلاله
اللبنانيون خيرا مع رفع عدد رحلات الطيران
اعلنت وزاره السياحه ان ايرادات الموسم
الصيفي لعام 2022 تجاوزت السته مليار
دولار لكن هذا الرقم لم يؤدي الى تحسين
عجله الاقتصاد خاصه ان المستفيدين فضلوا
ابقاء هذه الاموال داخل المنازل
يؤكد كارلوس صاحبه احد المطاعم النعامه
2022 كان الافضل منذ بدء الازمه لكنه
حفاوه المواسم السياحيه لم تلغي ازمه
الثقه فيرفض كارلوس كغيره من اللبنانيين
اذاعه ما يتبقى من ارباح داخل المسارف
بنخبيهم على المصاري وعلى هذا لانه يعني
الازمه فواتتنا بمشكله كثير كبير ومشغوله
تقبض الاكتريه كاش تفاعلها بتجيب منه
وللموظفين لانه ما بيقدروا يعيشوا من وراء
الباب
لكن هذه الاموال تحفظه في المنازل يستمتع
اللبناني
مصارف غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت
مباشره الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميله
فاطمه اليك
مشاهدينا اهلنا
بكملات اسواق المنطقه وايضا الاسواق
العالميه التي تشهد رالي حتى لو سمحت
سنوات مشاهدينا من وصولها الى سطح الكوكب
الاحمر اعلنت اداره الطيران والفضاء
الامريكيه الناس رسميا عن تقاعد مركبه
الفضاء الموجوده في المريخ انسايت وهي
خصيصا لدراسه الاجزاء الداخليه العميقه
للعالمين بعيد
[موسيقى]
السلطانه المحليه في البرازيل اعلنت ان
شخصين لقيا حدفهما على الاقل جراء الامطار
الغزيره التي ضربته ولايه سانت كاترينا
جنوب البلاد
[موسيقى]
وقفه مشاهدينا مع ابرز الصور واللقطات
لشهر مارس لهذا العام متابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في ختام النشره دوما نذكر بالعناوين
مواصله العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
الخزانه الامريكيه تعلن عن عقوبات ضد
المدعي العام الايراني واربعه من قاده
الحرس الثوري
بعد مفاوضات استمر بنيامين نتنياهو يعلن
التوصل الى اتفاق
بالبيروس
شكرا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]